I was going rose- best center ever
welcome back to the final probably
episode of Walking Dead episode 2 I
don't know this is beginning with you
know it's too dangerous
rusty get this thing shut down
I don't like that Lucas going in with
Kenny
does anyone know how to work one day you
know how to do this hey you're the one
with the degree what okay we'll watch
your back Nick scan the trees with me
I'm sorry what why would I be able to do
it I don't know how to do it I believe
okay well there's this button here and
there's this key here so I guess I'll
take the key and I'm working an ad
jammed
oh well that wasn't too bad actually
all right cool
no zambese
something right let me baby
that guy has no arms we don't have much
ammunition you got to get back to the
lodge they're behind us
now come on it can't be that hard to go
back right come on come behind me keV
all the zambese sound like alright let's
take this guy out nice shot kids alright
he's dead
[Music]
oh [ __ ] there's a lot of them oh hello
one what there we go
I understand I hit the circle but they
don't die come on what
oh [ __ ] that Carlos healthy a oh Sh he's
like you have my shirt you [ __ ] I
wonder how they get glowy eyes and [ __ ]
[ __ ] bad-ass I wouldn't mind being a
Tammy that's all I'm saying careful Club
eh oh oh don't trip don't trip
oh there's a gun there oh [ __ ]
come on come on our life go for the
knife
yup with the knife stabbed that [ __ ] in
the bite
come on oh that's debt bearing that dari
god damn Nick oh he's a good man after
all despite the unibrow
[Music]
come on just go in yeah wait what that
[ __ ] [ __ ] sorry folks
where's Rebecca Carver
you want Rebecca nice to see you too so
maybe he's someone who got in Rebecca
knocked up that'd be awkward when the
babies like so that would make sense
maybe he announced you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm gonna look forward killing her that
duck is sexy
stealth climber
look at this place
I don't understand why she went bad
but then again he made sense because she
didn't have a family in 400 days we knew
she was lying
[ __ ] what are we gonna do now bunny
power never you a a lot of Windows they
have a lighter how's that gonna help
these bills behave now the rest of them
could be anywhere
no that's bad idea man how the [ __ ] are
we gonna cover these guys and look for
them to Johnny cover that window
he's two knives I feel bad I hope he
doesn't die who do you both think are
gonna die tell them to come it's now
don't you
I think maybe the black guy and maybe
the unibrow guy no no I don't know I
don't like this so that guy with the
mustache have one hand right now he's
the guy from Kill Bill you know he the
guy who looks like this
he's pretty badass once where's Rebecca
someone look at me it's gonna be okay Oh
our baby deserves to be raised in a
place of safe I know you're out there
Alvin Luke and the girl this is real
simple you want this over quick you all
play nice and show your faces you'll
kill them holy we gotta go down there
I can't do that yeah back the baby you
need a doctor no where's Kenny
how the hell am I supposed to know we
have to help Carlos Carlos yeah the only
way to help him is to do what the man
says what about Luke and Kenny get those
guns we start shooting if people are
gonna die on both sides yeah uh sneak
out fine
what the hell is she gonna do and you
heard him however knows she's with us
I'm with a guy though yeah kill you
shoot him somebody to shoot it okay
Oh God you don't know that say goodbye
oh [ __ ] this is hard how is he gonna
have find them help anything
we have disappointing we have gonna kill
him
Rebecca we have to give up
ah here am i it reminds me of the mayor
in the TV show oh I bet you alright yeah
there's definitely something going on
there you don't want to dance please let
these people go just shut up oh those
fingers can you reach my hands
those aren't happy everything under
control I'll try I gotta give it a
chance
yeah it's not gonna work no no don't
move I don't like this
nice haircut man
I can't see him watch them
no no don't
[Music]
that's for our merit now I didn't want
to do this but you ain't leaving me much
choice so here's what's gonna happen I'm
gonna March another one of your friends
out here and I'm gonna put a bullet in
the back of their head well you can give
up now your choice you remember George
Alvin
see I do I remember a guy that was your
friend named George I remember when you
murdered him in cold blood and why
because you didn't like me
it could have lodged a complaint you
could have they could have been civil
hell no well do whatever you want I love
you back
ah no we can do this all night
is that what you want
where's Luke finally cut and run why am
I not surprised I warned you I warned
you not to follow him look where he's
led you he's the one bleeding but you're
safe now we're going home as a family I
told you
all right round him up we're heading
back to camp
[Music]
no don't in here god damn it
[ __ ] I don't know this could have
saved Walt but I know one of us didn't
just give up I know folks are sore over
what happened let's remember these are
our brothers and sisters and they all
have a vital role to play in this
community I really didn't want Walt to
die straight from the flock yeah that
don't mean they can't earn their way
back into the fold
I don't mean we can't find it in our
hearts to forgive them knowing full well
those who choose not to accept our love
surely wish that they had no shame a
storm is
goddamn I don't know man
I really don't know [ __ ] ok well let's
walk through this took blame for Sarah's
photo yeah guess it really didn't matter
who took the blame honestly I just felt
like Clementine is more mature than
Sarah at least and she should send up
for four others who did you sit with at
dinner
oh hey 34 I don't know I felt bad for
Logan I feel bad for Ken they're both
gonna be sad either way and LuAnn and
Ken did come over so I don't think it
really matter that much told Walter the
truth about Matthew 73 percent so yeah
and 86 percent Crimmins Walter to
forgive Nick which means Walter didn't
kill Nick I would assume I'm glad we
managed to do that at least but I'm
really sad Walter died
I left to find Kenny okay I don't know
44 stayed and helped Carlos Oh God our
baby deserves to be raised in a place of
safety
our baby you're out there today okay
we'll find Lukey I do want to see what
happened here I want to see if we can
save goddamned I don't like this man
let's see if I can get your attention
ah shame okay so we're out now and we
can that's kind of cool I say why would
we look through here just to see if he's
dead or night
so it doesn't look like he's actually
gonna kill him okay where's looking
Kenny
[Music]
there is lamb
thank hi
stab her in the [ __ ] him whatever
should have stabbed in all right
goddamn star
why would he say that how can they not
see him
[Music]
you all right
what are we gonna do I should have asked
her Lucas I don't know looks probably
took off
now they gave up
[ __ ]
looks like they got everyone who are
these guys
I've got a pretty clear shot on the one
just a little bit to the left don't
he'll kill them don't do it Kenny what
you idiot oh no no no no no no no no no
no no no I'm cheating I don't give a
[ __ ] okay where's the loot hell I don't
know just whining about something rather
so I told him to take a hike
he's gonna shoot either way it looks
like pretty clear shot we got to go find
Luke I don't know maybe we should go
find Luke he doesn't carry shoots anyway
see so there's no way to save him okay
we get the gist Sol I'm gonna go with
the first time I play it anyway because
they didn't they didn't do much good
anyway so yeah this is probably the best
episode in a while I really liked
episode 2 of season 1 and and I think
this was some some par with with that
one I thought this one was really really
good it felt epic and it felt like
things are finally getting started you
know and really liked it then we gotta
wait at least to once now for the next
episode which is just like but hey it's
worth the wait at least you know that is
a fantastic game series and I'm more
than happy that I can share this with
you bros thank you all for watching
thank you all for sayin through my
probably different decisions
and it's been a lot of fun I'll see you
in another series or it's not I'll see
you in the next episode whatever we make
sales press lobby
[Music]